zidane sanctionner le leader des bleus
est suspendu pour les deux matches à
venir il ne pourra pas participer aux
huitièmes de finale de l'équipe de
france
l'assemblée contre la réglementation
européenne les députés à l'exception des
verts ont adopté la loi visant à étendre
les dates de chasse aux oiseaux
migrateurs
alerte aux pollens les allergies que
vont à nouveau souffrir avec la vague de
chaleur découverte en trois dimensions
de la tacc du pollen dans l'organisme
avant le match états unis rend enquête à
téhéran sur le cinéma américain il est
interdit sur grand écran mais petit à
petit
hollywood sort de la clandestinité à
travers les cassettes de vidéos et puis
vente aux enchères dans quelques jours
d'une toile de georges de la tour un
événement on ne connaît que 39 toile
dans le monde de ce peintre génial l'une
de ses oeuvres a été retrouvé par hasard
elle sera vendue à prix d'or madame
monsieur bonsoir je vous le dise en
titre la sanction est tombée au milieu
d'après midi
zidane ne pourra pas jouer les 8e de
finale du mondial le meneur de jeu du de
l'équipe de france et suspendu pour les
deux matches à venir
une sanction qui se veut sans parti-pris
cocardier une sanction assez lourde pour
aimé jacquet le sélectionneur des bleus
va devoir recomposer maintenant une
équipe aussi performante que lors
d'épreuves deux premiers matchs viennent
la voix andré germain zinedine zidane a
été le premier à reconnaître son erreur
il n'aurait pas dû essuyé ses crampons
sur son adversaire son geste inexcusable
il va le payer cher
je suis français
j'avoue que deux matches c'est une
lourde sanction pour un joueur de cette
qualité qui représente qu'un à notre
football que nous aimons qui a un
comportement plutôt toujours positif
vraiment l'équipe de france est
lourdement pénalisé comme tous les
joueurs d'exception zidane est souvent
victime de ses adversaires et
l'arbitrage supposé protéger les
créateurs se retourne parfois contre
quel dommage
l'équipe de france b you nantes il ya
soir car real y avait assurément trouvé
la bonne carburation avec zidane en chef
d'orchestre
aimé jacquet va donc devoir repenser
entièrement son équipe en vue des deux
matchs à venir
il a prévu parce que le même soit
reproché mais bon maintenant on se
trouve dans le fait accompli je crois
que lui doit avoir plein de fiches plein
de deux schémas qui va pour appliquer sa
allemand jacques est tout de même
inquiet il sait qu'à partir des
huitièmes de finale les matchs sont à
élimination directe est que la france
devra donc se qualifie pour les quarts
de finale sans zidane est pour
il faut qu'ils sachent que l'équipe de
france jouera pour lui et sera aussi
déterminant que quand il était avec ses
potes et ses camarades une demi bonne
nouvelle est tout de même venue
éclaircir l'avenir des bleus la blessure
de dugarry serait un peu moins grave que
prévu il garde une petite chance de
rejouer dans une quinzaine de jours
si la france est toujours en lice
touchant de voir et puis le nigeria a
battu cet après midi la bulgarie 1 à 0
au parc des princes un but de victor
ikpeba le joueur de monaco
après deux victoires le nigeria est le
troisième pays qualifiés pour les
huitièmes de finale après le brésil et
la france
nous vous en parlions dès hier plusieurs
milliers de billets pour le mondial
appartenant à tour operator america
auraient été volés aujourd'hui le comité
français d'organisation exprime pour le
mois son étonnement il est vrai que hier
soir au stade de france
toutes les places étaient occupées alors
que certains billets dérobés concernés
ce match retour sera drôle de fric sac
avec sébastien libère le cambriolage des
bureaux de presse sports internationale
ceci aujourd'hui beaucoup de questions
les voleurs auraient escaladé ses
échafaudages ouvert une de ses fenêtre
du deuxième étage et forcé un coffre
fort à l'intérieur
selon les responsables de la société
quinze mille billets et environ 3
millions 500 mille francs
un cambriolage qui étonne beaucoup les
membres du cnf au cellier
existait-il là c'est une interrogation
que nous sommes en droit de nous poser
prime sport international affirment en
effet avoir acheté 40 mille billets au
cf aux questions pourquoi la société
après dix jours de compétition possède
rethel encore quinze mille billets
commandés pourtant depuis plusieurs
semaines par ses clients autre
interrogation prennent sport
international affirme que parmi les
billets volés figuraient des places pour
france arabie saoudite
or hier soir le cf fois fait ses
contrôles les places correspondante
oublier que nous avions vendu et s'ils
étaient bien occupés question ses
spectateurs ont ils eu le temps
d'acheter leurs places au marché noir
auprès des voleurs
difficile à croire en tout cas le
président américain de psi a porté
plainte et propose un million de francs
de récompense à qui retrouvera ses
mystérieux billets à trois jours du
match à hauts risques angleterre
roumanie manifestation à toulouse des
cafetiers et restaurateurs qui s'insurge
contre l'arrêté préfectoral leur
imposant de fermer depuis hier leur
établissement avant minuit et ce jusqu'à
lundi mesures prises pour éviter les
débordements éthylique possible de
hooligans véronique gaglione française
maison alors nous la joue bien et permet
un combat ceux travaillant à 11 heures
du soir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait bien évidemment par
les yeux fermés pendant le mondial
c'était la promesse d'un mois de fête
pour les tiroirs caisses mais voilà que
pour cinq jours cafetiers restaurateurs
toulousains sont priés par arrêté
préfectoral de fermer boutique à 23
heures si je devais fermer à 23 heures
comme prévu
j'aurais fait quinze couverts j'ai
ouvert plus tard j'ai ouvert jusqu'à 3
heures du matin j'avais 50 gr ils sont
tous arrivés entre 22h30 et 23h je pense
qu'on peut pour l'incapacité des
pouvoirs publics à pouvoir
juguler 100 ou 300 personnes qui sont
prêts à mettre le schisme neuville et
nous on est nous on n'est pas là pour
payer les pots cassés
c'est pas ces gens n'ont pas de canettes
vous savez et pourtant c'est des
canettes de bière qui qui qui servent
d'armes émissions de manière certaine
qu'il ya un préjudice et professionnels
sont spécialement visés par une décision
du préfet prise au nom de l'ordre public
il est normal qu'en retour ils soient
indemnisés et kas qui n'en sont pas à
demander des indemnités un recours
devant le tribunal administratif
prendrait trop de temps
il aurait voulu gagner au moins une
heure de travail chaque soir certains
prendront peut-être le risque ce soir
julie soutenir le maximum s'ils ont plus
fermement retenir aussi on va être
pénalisé parce que bon on va être obligé
de faire le couvre feu et on reprend
tout chez nous et ça sera un petit peu
dommage tout pour un vendredi soir ce
que le vent de l'histoire que des vidéos
qui bouge et donc c'est un petit peu
dommage pour l'autre
ce soir comme hier soir les patrons
c'est qu'ils aient les uns les autres
pour savoir quand ils vont fermer la
tolérance devraient aller jusqu'à minuit
ensuite il faudra à circuler il y aura
plus rien à boire à l'exception des
verts les députés dans un bel ensemble
ont voté l'adoption de la loi sur la
chasse aux oiseaux migrateurs la france
risque ainsi d'être condamné par la
justice européenne car cette loi est
incompatible avec le droit européen au
passage la majorité plurielle pourrait
perdre quelques plumes
jean baptiste prédalles yesha gregor
dans les jardins de l'assemblée
nationale on entend parfois le chant des
oiseaux
mais dans l'hémicycle la loi sur la
chasse aux oiseaux migrateurs a modifié
les clivages seul contre presque tous
les écologistes ne voulait pas rallonger
les périodes de chasse pour certaines
espèces
de son côté dominique voynet prônait un
compromis pendant le débat
on a invoqué des arguments parfois
bucolique comme le vanneau huppé
connaissez tous
quand le froid sec descendent du nord
vous voyez arriver des vols nombre
d'oiseaux apparemment noir et blanc qui
virevolte en rythme parfaitement
synchronisé aux cris très reconnaissable
du public
derrière les sourires et les cris
d'oiseaux une réalité à droite comme à
gauche on fait efforcé de ne pas
contrarier des chasseurs qui sont aussi
des électeurs en baie de somme c'est
vrai ça c'est clair dans le département
de la somme tous ceux qui vont à la
chasse à la hutte en particulier au
gibier d'eau
ce sont des les catégories populaires
donc c'est le seul loisir au moment du
vote certains ont préféré ne pas venir
d'autres ont cédé aux chasseurs 92 voix
contre 20 la loi est adoptée et
dominique voynet ne peut que le
regretter
la commission européenne est excédé que
le parlement européen est excédée et que
finalement l'image de la france elle est
très profondément dégradée par ce
comportement franchouillard la france
s'expose maintenant à des sanctions
européennes
pour dominique voynet la chasse
constitué un dossier piéger le piège à
fonctionner les étudiants de la région
rhône-alpes pourront poursuivre leurs
études à l'étranger grâce au vote cet
après-midi du conseil régional qui met
ainsi fin à un feuilleton qui a pris
naissance il ya plusieurs semaines avec
l'obstruction des et du front national
et ps répondant ainsi à la nomination de
charles millon didier guyot oui 96 non
47 abstentions
14 le dos le rapport est donc adopté ce
soir 3233 étudiants poussent un ouf de
soulagement
les crédits budgétaires pour leurs
bourses à l'étranger ont été enfin
accepté mais pour cela il aura fallu une
nouvelle fois que les élus se défiant et
s'invectivent
charles millon et ses fidèles ont voté
pour avec les conseillers régionaux
front national ces derniers sont
d'ailleurs pleinement satisfait charles
millon a accepté de revoir les critères
de sélection pour les étudiants nous
demandons qu'il y est un audit qui soit
fait sur cette politique ne le maroc on
se fixe également une limite financière
et nous demandons que l'on modifie les
critères y compris d'ailleurs pour les
rendre éventuellement accessible à
d'autres catégories qu aux étudiants de
faculté
l'année prochaine les étudiants devront
donc montrer patte blanche
le ps et les verts eux ont choisi une
stratégie d'opposition dure
bien sûr ils sont pour aider
financièrement les étudiants et pourtant
ils voteront contre
on ne se comprenait pas avec charles
millon et ses alliés
oui
c'est foyen
partir ayrault
impossible charles millon veut faire de
la région rhône alpes en laboratoire
politique mais devant le spectacle le
faire cet après midi par les élus on se
demande comment finir on sait violente
joutes oratoires et cette cacophonie en
corse l'état poursuit sa politique ma
propre sur l'île à travers deux
nouvelles affaires aujourd'hui le maire
de propriano comparaissait tout à
l'heure pour détournement de fonds
publics puis cet avis de la chambre
régionale des comptes qui épingle la
gestion de la ville d'ajaccio parce
qu'elle douce aimante josé boulesteix et
1000 mots qui est réputé plus bavard et
il n'a pas fait exception à sa règle ce
matin même si son procès lui est
exceptionnel c'est la première fois
qu'un élu de premier ordre de lille se
retrouve devant un tribunal
correctionnel
l'état reproche au maire de propriano le
remboursement très tardif d'une
subvention de 68 mille francs la
direction départementale de l'équipement
avait versé cette somme à et milwaukee
pour la réalisation d'une étude sur
l'urbanisme de sa ville études dont la
dde conteste l'existence
moi c'est pour faire il ne peut
simplement pas retenu comme chez moi que
soit livré un dépôt-vente fonds publics
c'est pourtant ce qu'affirme le
procureur même si la somme a été
remboursée cette année il réclame à
l'encontre des milwaukee 5 mois de
prison avec sursis et 20 mille francs
d'amendé jugement le 7 juillet autre
affaire à ajaccio cette fois mais même
sévérité de l'état dans un avis qui sera
rendu public la semaine prochaine
la chambre régionale des comptes
reproche ses dépenses à la ville les
magistrats n'hésite pas à préconiser
entre autres la suppression des
indemnités des élus
un camouflet pour le maire marc marc
angeli qui préfèrent garder le silence
sa ville est passé tout près de la mise
sous tutelle
les ennuis judiciaires de milwaukee et
le rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes sur la gestion d'ajaccio sont
deux signe supplémentaire d'une seule et
même volonté celle de la reprise en main
de la corse par l'état la fin je
laissais faire le conseil d'état
confirme cette décision demandant la
démission de fils de françois bernardini
de la présidence du conseil général des
bouches du rhône françois bernardini par
ailleurs premier secrétaire de la
fédération socialiste de la région
refuse de dire s'il va
michel le ministre des transports jean
claude gayssot annonce une nouvelle
réforme de la sncf pour l'ancien député
communiste qui s'était opposé à la
séparation de la compagnie en deux
sociétés distinctes
il n'est plus question de remettre en
cause le dispositif juppé mais de
l'adapter une réforme dans la réforme
avec la création d'un conseil supérieur
du service public ferroviaire
damien thévenot françois granet autour
de jean claude gayssot
les syndicats de la sncf au grand
complet à l'ordre du jour la réforme
une nouvelle réforme de l'entreprise
publique avant 97 la sncf c'était une
entité et une seule l'année dernière
bernard pons ministre des transports
d'un hp sein d'entreprises publiques en
deux sociétés distinctes
d'un côté la sncf chargée de
l'exploitation commerciale et de l'autre
rff réseau ferré de france en charge de
la construction des lignes et des
infrastructures au passage rff hérite de
l'essentiel des dettes de la sncf
134 milliards de francs la réforme
gayssot ne supprime pas les deux entités
mais elle institue une nouvelle
structure le conseil supérieur du
service public ferroviaire avec une
mission principale favoriser à la fois
la coordination les synergies à 10 entre
nos entreprises ferroviaires et rff et
de services déception chez les syndicats
le ministre n'est pas allé assez loin
il fallait supprimer réseau ferré de
france comme le député glisse au le
demandait quand il était dans
l'opposition
selon les syndicats le maintien de la
sncf en deux entités conduit forcément à
une impasse on va avoir des antagonismes
évident entre un propriétaire d'une
infrastructure qui va vouloir faire des
économies sur le réseau et une sncf qui
fait rouler des trains et qui dit auprès
de ses usagers
nous souhaitons améliorer notre service
ne soit nous souhaitons être plus
performant pour répondre à vos besoins
ja il ya là une incohérence dans le
discours qu'il va bien falloir régler le
ministre a bien annoncé aux syndicats un
désendettement supplémentaire de 37
milliards de francs du réseau ferré de
france
mais il n'est pas revenu sur l'esprit de
la réforme juppé
c'est ce qu'ils pourraient tous
les cheminots à envisager de nouvelles
actions dont les semaines à venir
l'inquiétude des salariés de giat
industries après l'annoncé d'un nouveau
plan d'adaptation qui signifie en clair
la suppression de près de 4000 emplois
en france dans le loir et cher par
exemple les employés de s'allouer sont
partagés entre amertume et résignation
arnaud bouter blaise creux ni sur les
murs de giat les vieilles revendications
sont rattrapés par l'actualité troisième
plan social en seulement quelques années
mais celui-ci risque d'achever le site
de munitions construits dans les années
20 au coeur de la forêt de sologne
ici on construit des obus pour le char
leclerc et les dernières commandes pour
les émirats arabes unis arrivent à leur
terme
il est évident que tout le monde parle
de ça même si depuis quelques années on
en est en a toujours été cité
on espère toujours que ça le bruit sera
sera sauvé salbris fait partie des sites
menacés tout à fait en dix ans le nombre
d'employés a été divisé par six dans sa
chute
j-1 salbris entraîne également des
dizaines de sous-traitants avant pour
nous l'armement représenter 40%
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'armement moitié à peu près
l'armement avec giat matra thompson il
reste le premier employeur
les commandes de l'état ont toujours
fait vivre le pays
difficile dans ces conditions
d'anticiper les conséquences de la
restructuration militaire
même lorsque la fin d'une usine est
annoncé depuis le temps je vous dis tout
le monde en parle
personne n'a jamais rien fait à personne
n'a jamais rien fait j'ai l'impression
que les salbrisiens malheureusement
prennent ça comme une fatalité
tout comme l'inévitable reconversion
dans le civil et le temps presse
thomson vient à son tour de fermer sur
la commune une de ses filiales dans la
sphère du meurtre de caroline dickinson
patrice pad et ce sans domicile fixe qui
avait été un 1er temps désigné comme
coupable demande aujourd'hui cent mille
francs de dommages intérêts à la justice
pour ces 17 jours de détention les
tensions qui ont fait basculer sa vie
dit il les français ne semblent pas trop
pressé de goûter aux aliments
transgéniques et en débattrons demain et
dimanche à l'assemblée nationale qui
organise une conférence de citoyens mais
je vous propose maintenant de voir
quelle importance ces cultures de maïs
transgéniques ont prises par exemple en
aquitaine depuis l'autorisation de
commercialiser ses produits en février
dernier les agriculteurs sont frileux
dominique barrouche frédéric de la rue
du maïs en aquitaine il y en a partout
mais du maïs transgénique
d'autres non mais
je n'ai pas la connaissance il se fait
du maïs transgénique les gens qui au
fond ne le disent pas quoi et pour par
crainte de représailles par crainte de
ce serait beau vous dire du maïs
génétiquement modifié en voici ni
pannonie marquage particulier à part une
déclaration à la mairie
au total on a identifié environ 170
hectares en aquitaine l'équivalent d'une
grosse ferme
la crainte de représailles des
adversaires aux trans génisses mais
n'explique pas tout les consommateurs
n'en veulent pas le chauffeur et le
phénomène du sang contaminé or
aujourd'hui les adeptes du génie
génétique et des biotechnologies
on les trouve dans les coopératives qui
vendent les semences et achète le maïs
produit
celles ci ont pourtant freiné la vente
du maïs transgénique ou maïs ogm faisant
porter le chapeau aux consommateurs nous
avons volontairement limité puisque le
l'ambiance générale et le consommateur
n'accepte pas encore la tragédie puisque
comme il n'ya pas encore suffisamment
expliqué quels services ça pouvait
apporter les ventes sont négligeables au
regard des énormes investissements
engagés par novartis
l'entreprise suisse qui a aujourd'hui le
monopole en france de la
commercialisation du maïs ogm minimise
l'échec commercial c'est pas un succès
mais c'est un lancement normal avec
seulement deux produits sur un petit
segment de marché potentiellement peu
importants
les deux seuls variété aujourd'hui
autorisés à la vente protège le maïs
contre la pyrale et la sésamie deux
chenilles rongeant la récolte mais ce
maïs là coûte 26 % plus cher une dépense
démesurée au regard du maïs perdu vous
avez un surcoût de 200 à 230 francs
à partir du moment où ce n'est pas
justifié pour quoi faire
dépasser cette somme au la productivité
rendement coût d'un côté ventes de
l'autre les agriculteurs sur leur compte
car comme on dit et paysans le premier
argent gagné c'est celui qui n'est pas
dépensé avec la vague de chaleur qui
s'installe en france les allergiques aux
pollens neuf ans une nouvelle fois
souffrir cette affection saisonnière qui
commence au printemps à pour responsable
vous le savez des substances contenues
dans différents pollens de fleurs et
bien pour la première fois nous allons
vous montrer les images de cette attaque
la trajectoire et les réactions sur les
cibles commentaires jean daniel
flaysakier un décor champêtre et
bucolique des fleurs des graminées tout
est réuni pour que se produise une
sensibilisation
c'est à dire la rencontre de l'organisme
avec des substances auxquelles ils
deviendraient allergique plus tard on
les appelle d'ailleurs des allergènes et
l'une des sources les plus communes de
ces allergènes ce sont les pollens on
les voit ici entrer dans les narines
parcourir les fosses nasales descendre
dans la gorge puis atteindre les
bronches
mais malheur à l'intrus les cellules de
défense repères l'allergène le cap elle
laval le coupe en mille morceaux et vont
coller chacun des morceaux sur leur
surface et une fois ce collage fait
elles vont appeler du renfort d'autres
cellules de défense dont le rôle va être
de passer les menottes aux envahisseurs
et on ne s'arrête encore pas là
l'organisme fabrique des agents
d'interception on les appelle des
immunoglobulines si l'ennemi revient il
aura à faire directement à elle elle se
pose sur de véritables bombes à
retardement des cellules bourré de
substances chimiques la sensibilisation
s'est faite un jour un mois ou un an
plus tard aux voix sinon même allergènes
cette fois ci la réaction ne se fait pas
attendre
les immunoglobulines capte l'ennemi et
c'est l'explosion
les cellules libèrent leurs contenus
notamment l'histamine et ces granules
d'histamine vont attaquer partout
ils vont d'abord irrité les nerfs
provoquant les sensation de démangeaison
et d'éternuements dans la profondeur des
bronches les vaisseaux se dilate à
l'intérieur des artères c'est la fois le
mans protéines des cellules commencé à
s'échapper
c'est ledem les bronches sont comprimées
leur calibre diminue le mucus épais si
c'est la crise d'armes tout simplement
lionel jospin au deuxième jour de sa
visite aux états unis pose un regard
séduit sur le système américain et
notamment sur la multiplicité des
emplois nouvellement créé un regard
pragmatique sur une amérique au travail
françoise david
ces deux hommes ont finalement pas mal
de choses en commun entre le président
américain et le premier ministre
français le courant dit on est passé et
ce dès la première rencontre
deux heures de conversation au cours
desquelles ses dirigeants se sont
découverts par est il des affinités et
des convergences sur l'avenir de la
planète
à l'aube du 21e siècle a washington
n'exerce pas multiplier les rencontres
temps avec le président de la banque
fédérale qu'avec le secrétaire d'état au
trésor
il a été question de la bonne santé de
l'économie américaine
ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est aussi de
mesurer une partie des ressorts de cette
compétitivité américaine de cette
capacité des états unis de se projeter
dans les nouvelles technologies et d'y
occuper des positions dominantes se
dynamise cette force c'est quelque chose
la fourche du calme de laquelle on a
envie d'aller voir et le premier
ministre de reconnaître que la majeure
partie des emplois créés aux états unis
étaient les emplois durables et
qualifiés et non des petits boulots
comme on avait pu le croire pour
parfaire une mutuelle compréhension
entre les deux pays rien ne vaut un
étroit dialogue lionel jospin et al gore
le vice-président américain le dauphin
de bill clinton sont tombés d'accord là
dessus
lionel jospin reconnaît qu'au fil des
années sa vision des etats-unis a un peu
évolué mais il l'affirmé il reste un
homme de gauche un homme de conviction
il faut simplement dit il savoir avancer
de façon pragmatique la crise au kosovo
avec cette demande de la france qui
réclame la réunion du groupe de contact
dans les jours qui viennent pour
vérifier si le président milosevic tient
son engagement de renouer le dialogue
sur place les deux communautés vivent en
parallèle c'est un système proche de
l'apartheid qui s'installe dans la vie
quotidienne
ces derniers jours serbes et albanais
enterrent leurs morts des cérémonies qui
exacerbe la haine de part et d'autre
c'est ce qu'ont ressenti sur place nos
envoyés spéciaux
jérôme bunny andry sera
ici au kosovo chaque jour amène ses
funérailles funérailles albanaise
funérailles servent aussi la douleur n'a
pas de frontières pas d'ethnie
cela dan était un jeune policier serbe
tués hier dans un accrochage avec un
groupe de séparatistes albanais à
quelques kilomètres de son village natal
au kosovo la haine se nourrit de ces
disparitions quotidienne les faire-part
punaisés sur les arbres de christina
entretiennent leurs sentiments
le face à face tendu entre serbes et
albanais qui ne fréquentent pas les
mêmes qu'à fait ceci est une université
serbe 10e graffiti dès l'école les
kosovars vivent un véritable apartheid
depuis que la région a perdu son
autonomie en 91 les étudiants et les
professeurs albanais ont été expulsés de
l'université seuls les étudiants serbes
restent dans des locaux trop grand pour
eux le fait que les étudiants albanais
et serbe soient séparés vous trouvez ça
normal
les étudiants albanais eux doivent se
contenter de maisons privées où ils
s'entassent en ce moment pour passer
leur examen avec des professeurs payés
grâce aux dons des parents travaux a été
transformée en une véritable colonie où
ils ont établi une ségrégation entre
étudiants alpes année et c'est le soir
les étudiants albanais fond la promenade
à part la ségrégation est entré dans les
mentalités
l'espoir d'une paix négociée n'en est
que plus lointain jean paul ii est
arrivé ce matin en autriche pour une
visite pastorale de trois jours la
communauté catholique secouée par le
scandale de ce cardinal accusé de
pédophilie est obligé de s'exiler en
allemagne jean paul ii a célébré cet
après midi une messe dans la cathédrale
de salzbourg devant quelques milliers de
fidèles à l'âme chalvron jean paul ii
semble être heureux de retrouver la très
catholique autriche à salzbourg tout à
l'heure quelques milliers de fidèles
s'étaient rassemblés sur la place de la
cathédrale
mais ni la marée des petits drapeaux
jaunes et blancs
ni l'accueil chargée d'émotion réservé
au pape à l'intérieur même de la
cathédrale ne doit vraiment faire
illusion
à quelques pas de là sur le marché c'est
plutôt l'indifférence
car l'église autrichienne est en crise
elle défie parfois ouvertement le
vatican et rue dans les brancards depuis
qu'une soixantaine d'ex séminaristes ont
mis en cause le cardinal groër ancien
numéro 1 des hiérarchies catholique pour
attouchements à caractère pédophile l'un
des accusateurs et ce prêtre devenu une
vedette des médias autrichiens
circulaire beaucoup de victimes de grand
air se sont rassemblés et avec elles des
membres du clergé et de l'ordre des
bénédictins
mais rome n'a absolument pas réagi à la
crise autour de la sphère du cardinal
gower à accélérer un processus d'érosion
de la pratique religieuse qui existait
déjà avant effectivement 114 mille
personnes se sont fait rayer
officiellement des listes des fidèles à
la suite de cette affaire
en quinze ans l'église autrichienne a
perdu la moitié de ses pratiquants d'où
cet appel pathétique de jean paul ii cet
après midi ne quittait plus l'église
à deux jours de la rencontre était unir
en alliant pour le mondial je vous
propose cette enquête à téhéran sur le
cinéma américain à cinéma interdite sur
grand écran mais petit à petit hollywood
sort de la clandestinité à travers les
films vidéo qui seul ou sous le manteau
au reportage christophe duchiron
frédérick basile
un jeudi soir à téhéran un samedi soir
chez nous à new york ou los angeles
on dirait que c'est le week-end
pour ceux qui aiment les symboles à la
fiche sur certains murs il est l'acteur
principal de la révolution l'ayatollah
khomeini la politique la religion les
interdits
maintenant pour ceux qui aiment le
septième art il ya le cinéma de quartier
ici l'épopée des héros improbables
n'avait avec des gros flingues et plein
d'explosions pourvoir titanic ou le
dernier de niro sur grand écran c'est
impossible
ces dernières semaines et c'est nouveau
seule la télévision a diffusé quelques
films américain malcom x ou robocop
pourtant en iran riche ou pauvre
religieux ou pas très pratiquants quand
on évoque les films d'hollywood et tout
le monde ou presque et dialogic de coire
même le cinéma américain a capté le
monde entier tout le monde aime ce
cinéma y compris en iran car les
américains ont la faculté de raconter
les choses simplement
et si pendant ces dernières années on
n'a pas vu de films américains ce n'est
pas que le public iranien n'en avais pas
envie mais c'est plutôt à cause de
l'atmosphère politique qui régnait aux
portes du bazar à téhéran à la recherche
d'un loueur de cassettes vidéo
pas facile c'est du marché noir un
commerce illégal
parce qu'il paraît en iran si on aime le
cinéma américain
et si on possède un magnétoscope tout
est possible
après une dizaine de refus enfin un
loueur accepte de nous parler mais il
veut garder l'anonymat
rendez vous à 14h une mallette pleine de
cassettes le dernier james bond ou alien
iv monsieur x nous assure qu'il ne fait
pas ça pour l'argent
stéphane beaulac la nuit les gens dans
mon genre ils font ça parce qu'ils
adorent leur travail ils aiment les
films qu'ils aiment hollywood et les
stars américaines
vous êtes déjà lyon prison de quoi à
cause de votre choix yes oui bien sûr
n'est pas pendant longtemps à chaque
fois trois ou quatre jours days
leonardo dicaprio le titanic à téhéran
une mauvaise copie loué au marché noir
voilà une famille qui aime le cinéma
américain et qui n'a pas peur de se
montrer car en iran il est temps
commence à changer
6 francs par film pour voir scènes
romantiques baiser corps dénudé de notre
religion vous savez c'est interdit de
regarder ce genre de scène ici pour les
gens la religion c'est quelque chose de
très puissant de même qu'à moscou v
n'osèrent londres paris ou tokyo
les produits sur d'outre-atlantique font
un carton à téhéran
comme quoi au cinéma n'en déplaise aux
plus conservateurs des iraniens le grand
satan américain n'existe pas
en écosse l'arrivée ce matin de la veuve
d'eric tabarly une présence toute
symbolique être aux côtés de l'équipage
du pen duick qui participent à partir de
demain au rassemblement de vieux
gréements auxquelles devaient se joindre
le navigateur etienne leenhardt comme si
rien ne semblait devoir être changées au
programme initial jacqueline tabarly et
sa fille marie ont tenu aujourd'hui à
faire le voyage de fer lit en écosse
tout au bout d'un ponton les pousses du
navigateur retrouve le pen duick
ensemble ils devaient participer demain
à la régate des plans fixes et bateaux
conçus ici depuis 130 ans pen duick en
est le plus célèbre fleuron et sur la
bôme cet après midi marie s'amuser
depuis hier le bateau préféré d'eric
tabarly attendait magistrale dans cette
bd cos cadeau inédit pour les habitants
du coin et drapeaux en berne
il était très connu ici comme français
comme marin c'est vraiment triste qu'ils
soient tombés à la mer
vraiment triste
aujourd'hui les derniers vieux gréements
sont arrivés sur place ici tabarly était
une légende et certains marins dans
après qu'une fois rentré au port que le
navigateur français ne serait pas de la
régate de demain je naviguais en mer
d'irlande c'est dans les journaux
en même temps que je ne savais rien de
cette prairie dans l'ombre jusqu'à ce
que j'arrive ici mon bateau est le sien
au pris la même route sort c'est
tellement saad
jacqueline tabarly et sa fille rentre ce
soir en france envy que pour granby ce
week end au cid sur les eaux calmes de
fer lit comme un hommage aux marins
disparus aujourd'hui record mondial pour
la vente aux enchères d'un tableau
d'eugène delacroix plus de 51 millions
de francs
tout à l'heure à l'hôtel drouot le choc
de cavaliers arabes c'est son nom une
toile datant de 1830 3 elle a été
achetée par un marchand d'art américain
le précédent record pour un tableau du
chef de file des peintres romantiques
avait été atteint en 89 avec la vente
d'une toile parti à 34 millions de
francs et puis autre événement dans le
monde de la peinture avec la semaine à
venir la vente aux enchères d'une oeuvre
de georges de la tour
à ce jour dans le monde il ne reste que
trente neuf tableaux signés de ce
peintre français de gêner suivant à
présent l'histoire inouïe de cette toile
baptisé la madeleine ne pénitente
considéré comme trois fois rien en 1980
gérard dalmaz michel levasseur
les experts de georges de la tour se
creuser la tête depuis longtemps
la madeleine pénitente cette merveille
ce cachet forcément quelque part 1980 le
dieu hasard la retrouve dans nos veines
label éplorée servait de devant de
cheminée dix sept ans après sa
réapparition la madeleine sortira en fin
de sa pénitence avec les enchères du 23
juin
une rédemption en cinq actes en 1981
j'ai une jolie vente un catalogue
beaucoup de monde dans la salle au
dernier moment quelques jours avant est
arrivé à tableau que personne n'a
vraiment regarder il est très noir les
experts ne s'y sont pas intéressés il y
a jugé quelques militants deuxième acte
l'antiquaire acheté ce tableau il le
revend à un collectionneur français qui
lui dit mais quand même est vraiment
trop salé trop noir
je vous laisse vous le ps je vous laisse
et vous me le nettoyer troisième acte à
rebondissements le tableau nettoyer
révèle la signature de notre génie du
clair obscur
l'antiquaire qui a déjà vendu la toile
un français ne s'embarrasse pas de
détails
il reprend la toile à son client
français et largo aux états unis acte iv
1983 il ya donc deux propriétaires le
français et l'américain
l'un et l'autre se bat et vont au
tribunal de new york l' affaire dure
quinze ans en 1996 le tribunal de new
york dit moitié-moitié débrouillez-vous
ensemble cinquième et dernier acte la
prochaine vente fifty-fifty américains
pensaient avec quote-part pour le
premier revendeur passer à côté du
pactole en 81 bientôt donc la pécheresse
contrite rejoindre à la gloire des
quelques tableaux sauvegarder du maître
des lueurs dans l'ombre y compris le
saint jean baptiste
retrouvez il y a deux ans à metz il
reste seulement 39 la tour dans le monde
dimanche ce journée nationale des
moulins à une initiative pour mieux
faire connaître ces monuments qui font
partie de notre patrimoine certains
d'ailleurs sont devenus de petits musées
vivants et on peut y voir comment se
fabrique et l'huile la farine ou encore
le papier l'exemple près de champerret
de ce moulin de la tourner
marie-hélène bono jean-pierre pasteur un
moulin ne s'arrête jamais celui de la
tournée était seulement endormi depuis
plusieurs siècles les plus un homme l'a
réveillé et l'a fait renaître de ses
ruines
jacques gaillard m pas petit comme
l'étaient les compagnons xiiie siècle il
a racheté le moulin il y 25 ont passé
dix ans à le restaurer aujourd'hui il
fait partager sa passion pour la
fabrication du papier à l'ancienne à
partir de vieux chiffons
c'est devenu de la fin autrefois 25
personnes travaillaient au moulin tous
les jours de l'année
l'apprentissage commencé très jeune dans
des conditions difficiles à minuit mon
avenir travail et de le mettre bas
belgique au mois et un enfant vieillard
au drame à 8 ans il va rentrer rangs du
lemboulas les dents et il va côtoyer
pendant dix ans au moyen-âge 50 kg de
pâte à papier sortait chaque jour de
semoule soit 500 feuilles
les enfants ont retenu la leçon et
compris pourquoi le papier c'est alors
si cher si on n'avait pas beaucoup
on a été longtemps pour en faire le
moteur vous fera dix ans pour faire un
livre
jacques gaillard est allé jusqu'au bout
de sa passion au premier étage il a
reconstitué un ancien la crise et
d'imprimerie
ici on peut fabriquer des livres à
l'ancienne c'est un musée vivant c'est
un atelier qui fabrique du papier et
imprimerie tous les jours avec des
techniques anciennes pour conserver
évidemment ces procédés qui ont fait de
nous ce qu'on évolue et la roue continue
de tourner le jour les papetiers
cultiver leur jardin pour améliorer
l'ordinaire mais il travaillait surtout
au coeur de la nuit et 7 halo de mystère
leur permettait de vendre le papier plus
cher
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres zidane
sanctionner le leader des bleus est
suspendu pour les deux matches à venir
il ne pourra pas participer aux
huitièmes de finale de l'équipe de
france l'assemblée contre la
réglementation européenne les députés à
l'exception des verts ont adopté la loi
visant à étendre les dates de chasse aux
oiseaux migrateurs dans un instant la
météo nathalie rihouet puis le point
route de valérie maurice je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2